closest we are ever going to get to
having savile on trial
he was there when the offense against my
client took place
he savile did take part in that offense
and through the guilty verdict today i
know that the savile victims
will take some comfort uh that there has
been a finding of
guilt associated with savile
what has the lives of these victims
been like uh since these incidents took
place oh
absolutely dreadful i mean these are
horrific assaults on on young
innocent girls at the time uh who have
had to live with this
horror and kept it to themselves for
years
and uh now have gone through the ordeal
of giving their evidence
uh before a jury and deeply deeply
traumatized by it all
when we use the word rape about uh
the defenses are we talking about
uh physical coercion yes we are we are
talking about physical coercion
on many girls uh who had uh
never been uh involved in any sort of
sexual relationship before
uh and it was truly truly shocking for
them
do you think that if you take uh terret
and savile together that this really
is uh the heart of the matter the people
at the center of this or
or are there more and other uh possibly
equally serious cases to come out well
terret clearly fed off uh savile's
notoriety and celebrity and and built
himself up
into some sort of uh celebrity himself
as you heard from
uh that video and it it's that uh
semi-fame that uh he used to lure
girls into his flat on many occasions
and there are others who also
used savile as a way of being introduced
to the young and vulnerable and so i'm
sure we haven't heard the last of it
but i want to commend those people that
gave evidence at the trial
uh it was extremely traumatic for them
and a very very brave
ordeal to go through and this will
encourage others to come forward
to learn that they can achieve justice
so many years after offences took place
do you think the culture has changed
significantly since then
uh i i think it is certainly changing uh
i think that uh the police are certainly
investigating these crimes with a much
greater level of sensitivity uh i think
that people
are no longer sitting in suffering in
silence as they used to
that they feel that they can achieve
justice and that this is not something
that a
a woman or any young vulnerable person
should have to tolerate i think people
uh
now have an inherent sense of what is
wrong
and are learning to speak up for
themselves and that can only be for the
good